et
notre invité politique ce matin c'est
donc il ya noursat bonjour je vous
remercie beaucoup d'être avec nous
adjoint à la mairie de paris pour parole
du parti communiste directeur de la
campagne de fabien roussel m'a parlé de
tout ça avec vous et ian brossât vous
attendez avec nous pendant 20 minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse quotidienne régionale
représenté par fabrice
hourlier de brossard et jour est bas les
journaux régionaux de l'est de la france
on commence en parlant de la crise
sanitaire ian brossât puisqu'à partir
d'aujourd'hui les tests sont payants si
vous n'êtes pas vacciné il reste gratuit
pour les personnes vaccinées ou pour les
tests sur ordonnance le gouvernement
raison procéder comme ça je ne sais pas
je trouve que il ya quand même une
dimension un peu punitif dans cette
affaire moi je suis très attaché à la
vaccination le parti communiste par la
voix de fabien roussel a appelé à une
vaccination généralisée très tôt le
risque quand même c'est qu'au final des
gens qui ne sont pas vaccinés ne se
fasse pas testé parce que ils n'auront
pas les moyens de payer ces tests et je
me méfie des effets pervers d'une telle
mesure vous craignez les effets pervers
olivier dussopt qui était à votre place
mercredi nous a dit les tests depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire c'est a
coûté 8 milliards à l'état est ce qu'à
un moment au gouvernement pour vous n'a
pas raison de mettre le holà mais je
comprends le raisonnement mais le
raisonnement qui consiste à punir les
gens au porte-monnaie pour les deux fait
un peu la manière de leur dire allez
vous faire vacciner de fait ça a été un
peu présenté comme ça c'est à dire que
si vous ne vous êtes pas fait vacciner
les tests deviennent payants et donc ça
devrait vous inciter à vous faire
vacciner moi je préfère la conviction
que cette politique qui cède à frapper
les gens au porte-monnaie est gêné par
la contrainte en fait oui enfin je suis
je suis surtout gêné par cette espèce de
chantage et je n'aime pas beaucoup cette
manière de s'adresser à nos concitoyens
et mais par ailleurs ça ne m'empêche pas
de dire et ça c'est un travail de
conviction a mené auprès des français
que la vaccination est la solution moi
j'en suis profondément convaincu vous il
ya un certain nombre de responsables
politiques qui ont relayé des discours
anti vaccin ça je pense que c'est très
grave moi je suis convaincu avec le
parti communiste avec fabien roussel que
la solution c'est la vaccination moi je
crois au progrès et quand le croit à la
science dans le primaire y compris pour
les soignants donc bien sûr la série
jonas d'ailleurs parfaitement normal
qu'on exige des soignants qu'ils se
fassent vacciner et donc oui bien sûr il
faut mener ce travail de conviction et
d'ailleurs je pense que y compris parmi
les gens qui ne sont pas encore vaccinés
il ya des gens qui ne sont pas anti
vaccins il ya des gens qu'il faut
continuer à aller voir il faut continuer
à mener ce travail de conviction mais je
préfère le travail de conviction
effectivement à la contrainte et la
suspension des soignants qui
ne souhaite pas se faire vacciner jeu là
aussi je comprends le raisonnement ce
qu'on attend d'un soignant évidemment
c'est qu'ils ne transmettent pas le coup
vide et donc la meilleure protection
contre ça c'est effectivement la
vaccination sur la question du pass
sanitaire le gouvernement souhaite le
prolonger jusqu'au 31 juillet prochain
est la raison pour vous je ne suis pas
scientifique et je ne suis pas capable
de dire aujourd'hui quelle est la
situation qui conduit à cette décision
nous avons émis des réserves dès le
départ sur le pass sanitaire je
maintiens que notamment dans un certain
nombre de quartiers populaires dans un
certain nombre de territoires ruraux la
solution c'est de continuer à aller au
devant des gens et de continuer à les
convaincre et ce travail de conviction
pour moi c'est la clé de tout et en
attendant le passage en terre et en
gardant en attendant et surtout mener ce
travail et je pense qu'on n'est pas au
bout de ce travail donc d'abord non un
outil complément dans la borne d'abord
on mène ce travail de conviction et
ensuite on peut envisager la contrainte
mais je ne pense pas que le gouvernement
soit allé au bout de ce travail de
conviction l'autre question c'est la
hausse des prix des prix de l'énergie on
va parler dans quelques instants
d'ailleurs de la question du nucléaire
et des prix du carburant qui augmente
qui connaissent des niveaux très élevés
plus élevé qu'au taux qu'au moment de la
crise des légions de gouvernement
devaient réfléchir à des mesures pour
aider les français pour vous ça doit
forcément passer par la baisse des taxes
mais évidemment et le gouvernement dans
cette affaire se conduit d'une manière
qui est invraisemblable sur le gaz ils
ont décidé de bloquer les prix une fois
que les prix y ont explosé et d'ailleurs
quand vous regardez ce qui s'est passé
depuis un an le calcul a été fait par
certains de vos confrères et qu'on
additionne l'augmentation du prix de
l'électricité l'augmentation du prix du
gaz l'augmentation du prix des
carburants en moyenne en un an les
français ont perdu 1100 euros par an
c'est à dire quasiment un smic qui est
parti en fumée du fait de la hausse des
factures d'énergie c'est monstrueux 1100
euros par an et on a face à un
gouvernement qui nous dit réfléchir
enfin on ne leur demande pas de
réfléchir on leur demande d'agir en
l'occurrence ils ont les manettes et
c'est la raison pour laquelle
effectivement avec fabien roussel nous
soutenons la baie des taxes sur
l'énergie les taxes et une part
extrêmement importante de la facture
donc le gouvernement à l'image de
manager tarifaire dont vous avez parlé à
la revalorisation du chèque énergie mais
quand même des actions de la part du
milieu le chèque énergie par exemple qui
est une mesure que le gouvernement lui
beaucoup est en réalité une mesure qui
s'adresse à une petite minorité des
français c'est sain élargir la c5
millions de ménages qui sont concernés
c'est vraiment des ménages et tant mieux
pour eux mais qui ont des tout petits
revenus les petites classes moyennes
celles qui travaillent elles n'ont pas
accès aux chèques énergie non la
solution c'est la baisse des taxes et
c'est la raison pas l'élargissement du
champ non c'est la baisse des taxes ça
suffit de racketter les français à coups
de taxes et d'avoir un état qui en
réalité profite de l'augmentation des
prix puisque l'augmentation des prix
conduit à a2 de l'argent supplémentaire
qu'ils rentrent dans les caisses de
l'état donc baisser les taxes la
solution c'est de baisser les taxes et
plus spécifiquement sur le carburant
c'est la remise en place d'une taxe
flottante qui ferait que lorsque le
baril lors le prix du baril augmente et
ben on baisse les taxes barbara pompidou
elle en appelle aux distributeurs à la
raison non mais on a un gouvernement qui
passe son temps en appeler aux autres
qui commencent par faire ce qu'ils
peuvent faire eux-mêmes en l'occurrence
les taxes ça dépend de l'état donc qu'il
baisse les taxes on est quand même plus
crédible quand on s'adresse aux
distributeurs si on a soi même pris ses
responsabilités sur ce qui relève de sa
propre compétence sur la question du
nucléaire il ya quelques heures emmanuel
macron a présenté son dispositif france
2030 avec plusieurs annonces notamment
sur le nucléaire qu'ils placent au
centre sa politique énergétique avec la
création notamment de minicentrale vous
êtes satisfait de ses annonces sur le
nucléaire de fait emmanuel macron
rejoint ce que le parti communiste dit
depuis toujours c'est vrai nous nous
avons toujours été constant sur le sujet
et des gens qui ont gaudi est d'ailleurs
macro lui-même puisqu'il a renoncé au
programme astrid nous avons toujours dit
que nous étions favorables à un mix
énergétique dans lequel le nucléaire
doit occuper une place absolument
centrale c'est quoi ce mix énergétique
c'est le nucléaire et les énergies
renouvelables
parce qu'aujourd'hui on a un débat qui
est très mal posée sur le nucléaire on
nous fait croire qu'il dre choisir entre
le nucléaire et les énergies
renouvelables non le sujet aujourd'hui
c'est de se débarrasser des énergies
carbonées celles qui polluent celles qui
produisent du co2 c'est ça le sujet
d'ailleurs le giec le dit très bien le
giec dit qu'on ne peut pas se passer du
nucléaire donc oui on a besoin du
nucléaire on a besoin d'investir dans le
nucléaire et c'est un débat que nous
avons y compris à gauche quand j'entends
les écologistes nous dire il faut sortir
du nucléaire quand j'entends les
écologistes nous dire il faut suivre le
modèle allemand regardez le modèle
allemand
c'est pas que c'est irréaliste c'est que
c'est néfaste
c'est d'ailleurs le principal échec
d'angela merkel le modèle allemand c'est
une énergie deux fois plus cher
deux fois plus polluantes au 2/3
importés enfin c'est ça qu'on veut quand
vous dites aux écologistes disent qu'on
parlait de la hausse des prix de
l'énergie c'est les français tout ça ça
va aller dans le portefeuille des cèpes
si on sort bien sûr je dis que ceux qui
prétendent qu'on peut sortir du
nucléaire et avoir une énergie à prix
maîtrisés menthe mantoue se trompe mais
en tout cas ça n'est pas la réalité et
si on veut avoir une énergie pas cher
une énergie décarbonée est pilotable on
a besoin du nucléaire on ne peut pas se
passer du nucléaire et ça n'est pas là
la réalité c'est très bien d'ailleurs
qu'on ait ce débat et l'élection
présidentielle doit être l'occasion d'en
parler d'envoyer au moins avec fabien
roussel et c'est d'ailleurs une vraie
qualité qui là nous disons les choses
nous portons les débats ces caches et
c'est ça veut dire qu'il ne faut plus
fermé de centrales ça veut dire qu'il va
falloir les remplacer tout cas il ya
billets à 225 centrales qui sont prévues
d'ici 2031 qu'on les ferme on est
maintenant mais ça veut dire qu'il va
falloir les remplacer investir dans de
l'année faire des petits se perd comme
l'a proposé fabien vous savez ça veut
dire que l'idée même qu'on puisse sortir
du nucléaire et s'en débarrasser est une
très mauvaise idée et je vous renvoie
une fois de plus vers le modèle allemand
enfin la réalité c'est que le nucléaire
est moins polluant beaucoup moins
polluant beaucoup moins émetteurs de co2
que le gaz et le charbon et on a des
gens qui voudraient comme en allemagne
nous faire revenir vers le gaz et le
charbon 20 ans il vaut mieux s'appuyer
sur le nucléaire sur une nouvelle
génération de de nucléaire et on s'en
sortira beaucoup mieux y a pas
d'alternative au nucléaire
il y a un mix énergétique qui doit être
élaboré avec le nucléaire
et les énergies renouvelables c'est ça
la sommation dans quelle proportion les
seuls à le mix énergétique il vise à
baisser la part du nucléaire à 50% mais
moi je ne lance pas au moins je ne pense
pas qu'on doive avoir pour objectif de
baisser la part du nucléaire dont 40 à
60 je vois là je n'approuve pas l'idée
selon laquelle face en vue l'objectif
devrait être de réduire la part du
nucléaire pour quelles raisons
qu'est ce qui justifie
qu'on ait pour objectif de réduire la
part du nucléaire le nucléaire c'est 70
fois moins polluant que le charbon c'est
40 fois moins polluant que le gaz est
pourquoi est-ce qu'on devrait renoncer
au nucléaire au nom de quoi et quels
arguments rationnels plaiderait pour
qu'on se débarrasse du nucléaire il n'y
en a pas et donc je pense que il faut
poser ses questions et il faut que tout
soit sur la table et que les français
puissent trancher y compris par leur
bulletin de vote et d'ailleurs ce que je
vois c'est que dans leur grande majorité
les français aujourd'hui approuve le
nucléaire ce qui n'était pas le cas et
quelques années mais aujourd'hui les
français sont largement converti à cette
idée on va passer à l'autre actualité de
ce jour ce jour c'est la journée hommage
à sa mère pattie dans tous les
établissements scolaires de france on
s'en souvient bien sûr un de ses
professeurs d'histoire-géographie
décapité à conflans sainte honorine
parce qu'il avait montré des caricatures
de mahomet en classe est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment un an après que les
leçons de ce drame ont été tirés
aujourd'hui
je le souhaite en tout cas et je pense
que
cette figure de samuel pâtit restera
encore longtemps gravée dans la mémoire
des français
et donc en tout cas je le souhaite oui
bien sûr je le dis aussi comme comme
enseignante puisque je suis sûr que dans
l'éducation nationale vous avez le
sentiment qu'aujourd'hui on a pris la
mesure de ce drame et on a fait ce qu'il
fallait pour protéger les enseignants et
pour garantir la liberté je pense à lui
je l'espère et on avait la main oui vous
avez un doute si vous nous dites deux
fois je l'espère si vous espérez pas
convaincu beaucoup d'enseignants merci
ya encore un déni loin ce sujet là mais
ils marquent un esprit il ne doit pas y
avoir de dénis et les enseignants
doivent être soutenus dans notre pays
leçon d'il le sentier je ne pense pas
qu'il le soit suffisamment eh bien il
par ailleurs je vois encore trop sur les
réseaux sociaux ou ailleurs de deux
profs bashing le travail que font les
enseignants notamment dans les quartiers
populaires n'est pas suffisamment
reconnus dans notre pays c'est pas sucé
pas uniquement une question de salaire
c'est c'est une question de la place
qu'on réserve à l'enseignant dans la
société ça magnifique métier le métier
d'enseignant et les enseignants ils
doivent être ils doivent être respectés
ils doivent avoir le droit d'enseigner
ski ski et ski et dans les programmes et
c'est ce pourquoi il occupe cette
fonction et il n'est pas normal qu'un
enseignant soit obligé de se censurer
parce que ça touche à la sensibilité de
tel ou tel aujourd'hui la saignante des
enseignants se censure aujourd'hui des
enseignants peuvent avoir peur d'évoquer
tel ou tel sujet ça n'est pas normal et
donc nous devons protéger nos
enseignants et les chérir parce que le
travail qu'ils font il est indispensable
un dernier mot sur un autre sujet mais
qui concerne toujours l'enseignement
cette professeur qui a été agressé il ya
quelques jours par an mais là il ya une
semaine d'ailleurs par un élève en seine
et marne l'agresseur jugé en comparution
immédiate qui a été condamné à cinq mois
de prison avec sursis c'est suffisant
pour vous je suis pas là pour commenter
des décisions de justice en revanche
c'est deux choses dans ces cas là il
faut des sanctions exemplaires et
lourdes 1 505 des lourdes et quand j'ai
vu sur les réseaux sociaux là aussi un
certain nombre de trouver des excuses à
cet élève m'enfin on est où on est où un
professeur il doit être respectée point
barre et un élève n'a pas à se comporter
comme ça jamais sous aucun prétexte
et deuxièmement on a besoin de moyens
soutenu pour l'éducation nationale
notamment dans les quartiers dans les
quartiers populaires on a besoin de
soutenir nos enseignants à la fois avec
bien sûr des salaires revalorisés mais
surtout avec davantage d'enseignants et
c'est la raison pour laquelle fabien
roussel propose 90 mille embauches dans
l'éducation nationale ça me paraît
primordial et nous proposons aussi je
sais que ça fait un peu débat
d'augmenter le temps d'enseignement
fabien roussel a proposé que dans le
temps dans le secondaire on soit 32
heures par semaine que les élèves soit
32 heures par semaine en classe et ça
moi je laisse en 2h12 cet enseignement
très le zoo avait bien les professeurs
sont beaucoup plus je la remplace les
élèves jeunes et je ne suis pas
favorable à ce qu'on augmente le temps
de travail des enseignants en revanche
que les élèves soit 32 heures par
semaine en classe oui tout à fait et je
préfère que les élèves soient en classe
plutôt que de traîner dehors et par
ailleurs c'est la garantie que les
élèves feront leur devoir en classe et
pas à la maison ce qui génère un certain
nombre d'inégalités ian brossât on va
parler un mot sur ce qui s'est passé
cette semaine au conseil de paris c'est
un conseil de paris qui a été agitée on
va voir d'abord cet extrait de ce qui
s'est passé puis derrière je vous fait
réagir
même quand j'étais prof à sarcelles les
élèves se taisaient dont vous allez
faire pareil je m'en fous madame je m'en
fiche
je n'en ai strictement rien à faire
madame vous adressiez à rachida dati ça
fait beaucoup réagir notamment à droite
et pas seulement des luttes paris ans
damien abad a également réagit valérie
pécresse a également réagi charles lynch
a pas parlé d'agression
comment vous expliquer ce qui s'est
passé est ce que vous regrettez
aujourd'hui n'avoir pas mais qu'est ce
qui s'est passé en l'occurrence c'était
les questions d'actualité du conseil de
paris une question m'étaient posées par
un élu socialiste
je n'ai même pas pu entendre la question
qui m'a été posée puisque rachida dati a
en permanence couvert la voix de cet élu
je tente de lui répondre sans avoir
entendu la question qui m'a été posée et
lorsque je réponds je n'entend même pas
ma voix alors ça ne se voit pas sur la
vidéo puisque comme au sénat d'ailleurs
la captation fécond en tant que la
personne dont le micro est allumée mais
en l'occurrence madame dati parlait en
permanence et donc ce que je dis
simplement c'est que si et vous savez
comme journaliste il vous arrive
d'animer des débats si tout le monde
parle en même temps on est inaudible
c'est pareil est ce que vous regrettez
le choix des mots nous avons prié es tu
es du temps aussi mais mais mais est ce
que madame dati regrette d'interrompre
systématiquement les personnes qui
parlent est ce que un débat démocratique
c'est des gens qui s'interrompent en
permanent de regretter par le choix de
vos mots venant des élus de la
fédération des républicains in paris
demandé j'ai bien vu usés ce matin parce
que ce que non parce que ce que je dis
simplement c'est que si on veut qu'un
débat fonctionnent normalement il faut
que les prises de paroles soient
respectées pour le reste j'ai de
l'estimé pour madame dati juste reyer
déjà dit à de nombreuses reprises je
n'enlève rien à l'estimé que je lui
porte simplement j'aimerais qu'on puisse
avoir un débat normal et un débat normal
c'est de respecter le tour de parole
c'est quand même pas exorbitant de
demander que les gens parlent les uns
après les autres oui je suis je suis
évidemment envoyé un message pour lui
redire l'estimé et le respect que je lui
porte mais mais simplement le reste le
respect c'est aussi le respect du tour
de parole enfin les gens le savent quand
ils font un dîner chez eux ou pas la
parole en permanence ils attendent que
l'autre est finie avant de commencer
mais ça doit être pareil au conseil de
parler de la campagne présidentielle
maintenant ian brossât je le disais vous
êtes le directeur de campagne de fabien
roussel comment on fait pour être
adjointe anne hidalgo et directeur de
campagne de fabien roussel mais on sait
moi je suis adjoint à la maire de paris
la maire de paris les socialistes elle
s'appelle anne hidalgo je suis
communiste date face à l'aja moussavi
mais elle lancé m oui bon on ne vit pas
comme un affrontement est par ailleurs
les choses sont très claires elle sait
que je suis communiste et quand elle m'a
nommé adjoint en charge du logement elle
savait que j'étais communiste et elle
savait que si le parti communiste avait
un candidat à l'élection présidentielle
je le soutiendrai donc comment dans
cette affaire tout le monde est loyal
tout le monde est franc vous essayez ça
travaille bien ensemble avec eni la wii
nous travaillons bien ensemble je suis
très fier d'avoir contribué à faire en
sorte que paris compte 24 % de logements
sociaux très fiers de mettre en place
l'encadrement des loyers pour soulager
le pouvoir d'achat des classes moyennes
dans suez ça se limite à paris où il
peut y avoir une candidature commune
puisque vous travaillez bien ensemble à
paris on pouvait pas travailler bien
ensemble la france d'abord aux dernières
élections municipales il y avait pas une
candidature commune à l'ensemble de la
gauche il y avait aussi une hélice
attirés par les verts dans ce qui nous
concerne nous effectivement nous étions
avec anne hidalgo dès le premier tour
c'est pas le mode de scrutin et
l'élection présidentielle c'est pas
l'élection municipale l'air vous savez
y compris lorsqu'il y avait de fortes
tensions à l'échelle nationale entre les
communistes et les socialistes
ça ne nous empêchait pas de travailler
ensemble à l'échelle ça peut avoir des
conséquences sur la majorité municipale
à paris on a l'impression qu'il ya des
tensions avec les verts aussi notamment
est ce que la majorité municipale risque
d'exploser
en vue de cette campagne présidentielle
cela serait une très mauvaise chose et
vous ne l'expliqué pas mais en tout ça
ne dépend pas en tout cas pour ce qui
dépend de nous les communistes nous ne
ferons rien qui aille dans ce sens là
mais en tout cas je pense qu'il faut
préserver ce que nous savons faire à
l'échelle locale et si les français
encore un peu de destine pour la gauche
c'est parce que nous faisons de bonnes
choses à l'échelle locale ça c'est vu
aux dernières élections régionales vous
évoquez l'encadrement des loyers tout à
l'heure cette semaine un chiffre très
intéressant et sorties 6000 élèves en
moins dans les écoles parisiennes la
faute au logement la faute à des prix
trop cher oui des prix trop cher à
l'accession à la propriété des prix trop
cher au niveau des loyers et donc il
faut tout faire mais c'est ce pourquoi
je me bats pour mieux maîtriser les prix
les prix du logements effectivement il
ya aussi d'autres éléments qui entrent
en ligne de compte le développement du
télétravail
l'aspiration à vivre dans une maison et
un jardin ça peut concerner un certain
nombre de gens qui du coup préfère aller
en deuxième couronne ça existe aussi
mais en tout cas pour ce qui me concerne
moi mon boulot c'est effectivement de
faire en sorte que les prix soient plus
maîtrisée c'est l'objectif que nous nous
sommes fixés renard aimant pour revenir
à la campagne
du coup il ya un dialogue entre anne
delbée fabien sait vous connaissez
fabien roussel je crois que vous l'avez
reçues il n'y a pas très longtemps il
discute avec tout le monde fabien et
c'est quelqu'un qui est très ouvert et
qui est la france
à saisir ça trouve sympathique nous
avons un candidat c'est fabien roussel
et fabien roussel sera candidat à
l'élection présidentielle nous avons
nous aurons très prochainement nos 500
parrainages sans difficulté particulière
et donc nous sommes à fond et fabien
roussel sera sur la ligne de départ pas
de doute là dessus et quant à elle ne
pense autres jeux pas tout seul avec
avec plein de gens qui vont nous
soutenir mais en tout cas fabien roussel
sera candidat un mot juste sur fabien
aussi puisque la semaine dernière il a
dit qu'il voulait une loi pour rendre
inéligibles les personnes condamnées
pour un soutien peut passer pour une loi
anti zemmour alors lui dit que c'est pas
une loi anti zemmour est ce que du coup
cette fois elle va être déposée tel quel
ou pas du tout est-ce qu'il va avoir un
petit peu un recul sur ce sujet de la
part des députés tout ça partout sa part
de 2,2 constat d'abord eric zemmour a
proposé de supprimer la loi gayssot qui
la loi portait à l'époque par jean
claude gayssot lorsqu'il était député
député communiste de seine-saint-denis
qui condamne les propos et les actes
racistes et antisémites et zemmour a dit
qu'il voulait la supprimer cette loi
mais nous ce que nous disons c'est que
nous ne souhaitons pas la supprimer nous
souhaitons la renforcer et nous
souhaitons effectivement que quelqu'un
qui a été condamné pour de tels propos
raciste antisémite anti républicain soit
déclaré inéligible et donc nous
travaillons aujourd'hui à l'assemblée
nationale avec nos députés un projet de
résolution sur ce sujet donc en projet
de résolution dont keith a pas une
proposition de louis puisque
effectivement il s'est avéré je crois
que le conseil constitutionnel a
considéré qu'une telle disposition
porter dans la loi serait
anticonstitutionnel m'enfin moi je suis
quand même attaché à ce qu'il y ait bien
sûr la liberté d'expression mais il ya
aussi des limites à la liberté
d'expression et le racisme
l'antisémitisme ce n'est pas une opinion
c'est un délit et donc on ne doit pas
pouvoir être élu si on a été condamné
pour des propos racistes ou antisémites
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été notre
ce matin même
[Musique]